see there are certain things you can do
certain routines or outfits you can put
on that will essentially trick you into
answering a certain state of mind what I
like to call the showtime trick almost
like an actor putting on a costume
before getting ready to perform in front
of the camera or an athlete doing a
special ritual before their game for
example LeBron James will throw some
chalk dust up in the air before playing
ball all of these unique rituals are
essentially ways for us to trick our
mind into putting our game face on it's
a way for us to tell our brain and body
hey it's show time it's time for us to
act a certain way and give it your all
none of us are born with these rituals
you have to build an association in your
mind almost like how you would build a
habit obtaining a ritual for the
showtime trick can actually be very
simple all you need to do is purposely
go out of your way to create a new
ritual and make sure that you do
something special immediately after the
first three times